let's talk data here's data for you
uh historically who in your life
shifted your way of thinking give me
three names who in your life that you
think about
[ __ ] and what part of say politics
capitalism you wait
in politics and capitalism was you okay
okay give me two other names who in your
life got you to think of certain things
it could be spiritual yeah it could be
marriage it could be finances it could
be
business it could be politic who flipped
you does it have to be
somebody i met or is it can it be
something no not at all it could be a
great it could be a distance yeah it
could be a militant freedom i've never
met milton friedman right yeah who who
could it be for who's it for you flipped
or just influence in general
for you to say damn that makes sense you
know what maybe they want to thank you
right now
yes yes okay uh to me for for uh
on a personal level to be a little bit
more careful with my decisions and who
i'm around
i'm gonna say it's gonna be my
grandmother okay she's like very like
hey be aware of who's around you not
everybody's your friend because i used
to be very um
trusting you know they're not like
trusting me like you're young and naive
so you think everybody's out to help you
uh with politics and in uh with politics
and capitalism obviously it was you
and then um as far as uh taking things a
little bit more
uh to a whole other level of um
of uh uh making a um how can i explain
it uh making it a uh
an actual um career not career but a uh
uh making a bold move in a statement i
think to me is gonna be
my buddy jesse with lexi like hey we
really need to push
it's not just you believing in your
perspective on
what's happening with america we need to
drive this to the
jesse jesse from so so from legacy
movement so
pbd yeah jesse grandmother yeah okay
who's for you
three names um well i i don't know his
name it's crazy but one of the most
influential moments of my life was that
navy seal gave the speech
uh when i was with the cardinals you
told me that story that's
sick that was that was one of the most
that was like transformative
uh you called it the best motivational
speech you've ever heard and you've
heard thousands
yeah and it tell everybody since they're
listening could be good for them to hear
it
okay um all right so when i when i was
in the minor leagues one of the things
that they
they do is they have these they bring
everybody into an auditorium once a week
i i imagine similar like you know sales
executives
and they give these motivational
speeches and they have these speakers
come in and they get
you know an hour and it's normally
horrible it's normally the worst hour of
your entire week you got to listen to
this guy
you know try hard if you're not working
hard the other guy blah blah blah blah
we're like yeah we don't we got that
like we didn't get here by not working
that jerk yeah but there was one guy
came in he was navy seal
knowing these guys wear suits and
everything like that this dude was in
t-shirts jeans and flip-flops kind of a
little dude like not like what you would
expect the navy seal or whatever
and uh he stands up and he's like who
here has heard uh
pain is weakness leaving the body and
we're like ah here we go again he's like
that is the dumbest [ __ ] anybody's ever
said out loud we were like what
he was like who here has heard that if
you're not working hard
somebody else is gonna outwork you and
when you meet them they'll win
and we were like yeah they were like
yeah cause rest isn't important and like
you know if you if you over train and
tear your
tear your knee did your did your acl
lack will
and so we're like what is this guy
talking so the anticipation is
unconventional
everything we've ever heard it turns it
is what makes and he says this is the
deal man
he goes this sucks
waking up at six o'clock in the morning
and running and working out and then
going for batting practice all day
and then hitting the gym and that that
sucks
but you do it anyway and you can't trick
yourself
into saying something that sucks doesn't
suck you can't be on the third mile
of a three and a half mile 95 degree run
yeah and be like
this is great i love this no it's
horrible but you do it anyway
and everybody else when it gets horrible
they quit and that's why you're you and
they're them
know it sucks and do it anyway embrace
the suck
that was his whole thing embrace the
suck so number one embrace the suck navy
seal who else give me two more
uh two more the second one was jordan
peterson somebody that you've
interviewed very very very influential
in my life and the third one it probably
isn't one person i went into college a
pretty liberal dude very anti george
bush very anti
uh uh blood for oil it was all the
liberals in my college that were doing
like performative stuff and i was like
man i am definitely not one of them
so it's crazy you've told that story
watch this year so watch this here
he just gave his three you gave your
three navy seal jordan peter some
liberal liberals at the college you went
to a bunch of people by the way i'm
curious i want to hear you or somebody
some people are saying they got a list
here so i'll give you some of the names
jordan peterson
uh uh is out here by a lot of people
uh rogan pbd jordan peterson larry elder
trump
uh prophet muhammed a guy
said that's anastasia that's interesting
thomas
ben shapiro tim cast mom brother-in-law
you're hearing already listen
friedman reagan thomas soul uh uh
uh so anyways you're going through david
goggins tony robbins all these names
right when you sit there and think about
it
um i would have to say
my three i would put milton friedman in
that list
okay 100 milton friedman's got to be on
that list for me um
i would put
i'm trying to say milton friedman would
be one uh
i'd have to put uh ein rand on that list
with atlas shrugged oh i'll shrug yeah i
would have to put that on the list
um there's a there's a guy named mano
that most people won't even know the guy
played a very important role
even though something stuff happened to
him he was a very important guy for me
m-o-n-o m-a-n-r meaning guy we used to
go to his place and we would sit there
from friday nights every friday night
for about two years from six o'clock to
two o'clock in the morning
we debated uh religion and politics is
what we did
wow and from 6 p.m to 2 in the morning
with myself
it was myself armond uh
our men who ended up committing who took
his life and a couple other things
stories that we had that we go there
anyways so these guys flip me but you
know
example why it's that but flipping is
different there's an example there's
flip i'm talking flipping flipping is
you're sitting you're like
damn i never thought about that way
before right i never thought the art of
flipping
is not people who are extremely loud
emotional that's not you are flipping
no very subtle obama flipped people yeah
and he did it in his own way obama did
obama got republicans to say
this guy's not that bad let me vote for
this guy he's a flipper okay
trump flipped people like him or not he
flipped people
yep he got some people to say i like
this guy bill clinton
flipped people reagan flipped people
reagan when he won and the day of
inauguration
khomeini sends all the different pows 30
minutes after he's given his speech
and he says this happened because of
jimmy carter he didn't take the credit
so he got the democratic audience to say
[ __ ] how do you not like this guy man
freaking give them credit
to the guy he just beat you gotta love
this guy right
he flipped people the art of we need
more people today
who are learning how to flip instead of
talking to people like they're idiots
nobody flips when you think the audience
is an idiot
not on the left not on the right the art
of flipping people is not
what an idiot what makes they're not
going to flip like that there's got to
be completely different way to
presenting an argument to a person to
say
you know i never thought about that
that's the key what you just said
presenting an argument having an actual
real debate it doesn't happen now it's
all canned
debates that's really just propaganda
it's really just
their message in the form of a quote
unquote debate
but nobody's having these conversations
these open and honest conversations you
know like
and there has to be some sort of it's us
too we got to check ourselves as well
like we have to allow ourselves to be
open
to that new information as well right
like it can't just be like
you know what what's uh you you said
something once that was really really
smart pat and it was
it was something to the effect of too
many people listen
to talk they don't listen to hear right
like i think and that that's the true
reply
yeah and i i do that as well as well
like i i'm as guilty of that as anybody
it's like especially when i'm in a
debate
i think it's human nature to want to do
that so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you